l'hôtel de la préfecture
dans les années 1730 la compagnie des
indes de construire des entrepôts près
les marchandises importées et le café
produit dans l'île le plus important
d'entre eux se trouve à saint denis
commandé par le gouverneur mahé de
labourdonnais cet édifice en pierre fait
aussi office de fort
vers 1770 il devient la résidence
officielle des gouverneurs elle n'aurait
remplacée par une grille et les
terrasses couvertes de toitures en
charpente
quand en plus tard le monument est un
nouveau restaurer et embellit on ajoute
côté mer en avant corps monumental
surmonté d'un dôme aujourd'hui disparu
lors de cette même compagne de travaux
la façade principale est enrichi de
colonnes et de pilier néo classique
accès principal au bâtiment lave encore
précède une élégante varangue qui
dessert différents bureaux dont celui du
préfet
un très bel escalier en bois à double
révolution mais nos pièces de réception
du premier étage
les salons qui accueille aujourd'hui
encore les personnalités officielles de
passage à la réunion sont décorées de
meubles de tableaux anciens
l'ale est abrite également les
appartements du ministre bureau ou
chambre ni à la disposition des hôtes de
marque
les travaux de modernisation confiée à
l'architecte jean hébrard dans les
années 1950 sont à l'origine de la
physionomie actuelle du bâtiment
préfecture depuis 1946 cet édifice qui
symbolise le pouvoir central à la
réunion est aussi l'un des tout premiers
monuments historiques de l'île